TEST IN THIS MONTH'S PRIMARIES.
>> WE WILL WATCH AS THE NUMBERS
COME IN.
JOHN KING, THANK YOU.
>>> NEW AUDIOTAPES.
A HIGH PROFILE REPUBLICAN IN
CONGRESS SPEAKING AWAY FROM THE
PUBLIC ON JANUARY 6 ABOUT HIS
OWN PERSONAL BELIEFS INVOLVING
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS
BEHAVIOR ON THAT DAY.
THIS TIME, SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM, THEY COME FROM THE
REPORTING OF TWO "NEW YORK
TIMES" REPORTERS AND ALEX BURNS
AND JONATHAN MARTIN AND THEIR
NEW BOOK.
THEY JOIN ME NOW.
JONATHAN, YOUINTERVIEWED
SENATOR GRAHAM.
I WANT TO PLAY SOME OF THE
AUDIO.
>> WE WILL COME OUT OF THIS.
MOMENTS LIKE THIS RESET.
PEOPLE WILL CALM DOWN.
THIS IS A GROUP WITHIN A GROUP.
WHAT THIS DOES, A RALLYING
AFFECT FOR A WHILE.
WE ARE BETTER THAN THIS.
>> IF YOU CAMPAIGN JANUARY 6 TO
TODAY, HOW STARK ARE THE
DIFFERENCES?
THAT LINDSEY GRAHAM PUBLICALLY
SAID HE HATED THE WAY IT ENDED
WITH HIM AND TRUMP.
HE HAD ENOUGH.
>> YOU CAN ALMOST HEAR HIS
VOICE, SENATOR GRAHAM TRYING TO
PLAY OUT WHAT THE IMPACT OF THIS
ATTACK, WHICH AS WE TALKED WAS
STILL ONGOING AS WE SPOKE THAT
AFTERNOON ON THE 6th.
IN A SECURE LOCATION AFTER THE
CAPITOL WAS EVACUATED.
THE CAPITOL POLICE WERE STILL
TRYING TO CLEAR THE CAPITOL IN
THOSE MOMENTS.
GRAHAM IS THINKING AHEAD.
HE IS THINKING ABOUT THE
POLITICAL IMPACT ON HIS PARTY
AND THE IMPACT ON THE COUNTRY.
COULD THIS BE A 9/11 MOMENT
WHERE THE COUNTRY RALLIES
TOGETHER?
WHO BETTER TO LEAD THE COUNTRY
THAN A FIGURE LIKE THE NEW
PRESIDENT, GRAHAM'S OLD FRIEND,
JOE BIDEN?
MY GOODNESS, THOSE TWO
ASSUMPTIONS IN THE DAYS AND
WEEKS LATER WOULD OBVIOUSLY
PROVE TO BE ERRANT.
COUNTRY DID NOT COME TOGETHER.
IT DEEPENED THE PARTISAN
DIVISIONS.
JOE BIDEN WAS NOT ABLE TO RALLY
THE COUNTRY.
HE IS ONE MORE PARTISAN ACTOR ON
THE POLITICAL SCENE.
>> IS IT CLEAR TO YOU WHAT MADE
GRAHAM FLIP BACK?
I CAN'T REMEMBER, WAS IT THE
NEXT DAY HE FLEW OUT AND HE WAS
HECKLED.
HE SEEMED UPSET.
WE REACHED OUT TO SENATOR
GRAHAM'S OFFICE.
HE STANDS BY -- IF HE STANDS BY
THEM.
THEY SAID, SENATOR GRAHAM SAID
THE JOE BIDEN WE SEE AS
PRESIDENT IS NOT THE ONE WE SAW
IN THE THE SENATE.
HE WOULDN'T SAY WHETHER HE
STANDS BY THE AUDIO.
>> SENATOR GRAHAM IN THE DAYS
AND WEEKS AFTER JANUARY 6, AS WE
CAPTURE IN THIS BOOK, THEY
THOUGHT THAT MAYBE THIS WAS IT.
MAYBE IT WAS TIME TO TURN THE
PAGE.
JUST MAYBE, THEIR VOTERS WERE
WILLING TO TURN THE PAGE FROM
DONALD TRUMP AND PUT THE LAST
FOUR YEARS BEHIND THEM.
WHAT HAPPENED IS, WHETHER IT WAS
IN THE AIRPORT OR VIA EMAIL OR
CALLS OR OLD-FASHION LETTERS,
GOP LAWMAKERS FOUND OUT THEIR
VOTES DIDN'T WANT TO MOVE ON.
THEY DIDN'T WANT FEEL
PARTICULAR
PARTICULARLY ENAMORED BY BIDEN.
IT WAS BACK TO NORMAL.
NORMAL WAS DONALD TRUMP.
>> PEOPLE WON'T WANT TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH WHAT HAPPENED
JANUARY 6.
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED.
KEVIN McCARTHY SAID THE
PRESIDENT BARED RESPONSIBILITY.
DOES THIS COME DOWN TO HIS
INFLUENCE AT THE BALLOT BOX?
>> SETTING ASIDE THE IRONY OF
CALLING DONALD TRUMP A SECRET
ANYTHING, IT DOES COME DOWN TO
HIS INFLUENCE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT TRUMP'S
INFLUENCE IN REPUBLICAN POL
POLITICS, THEY ARE MORE WITH HIM
THAN ANY OTHER LEADER.
ONE OF THE BIG CHALLENGES THAT
WE OUTLINE IN THE BOOK FOR
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH TRUMP OR
PRIVATELY EVEN SHARPLY CRITICAL
OF HIM IS, HOW DO YOU TRY TO
LEAD THE PARTY IN A DIRECTION
THAT IS DISTINCT FROM TRUMP'S
DAY TO DAY EDICTS BUT DOESN'T
LEAD INTO CONFLICT WITH HIM.
WHAT YOU HEARD IN GRAHAM'S
VOICE, THE THINGS WE QUOTE IN
THE BOOK, THERE WAS THIS HOPE IT
WOULD HAPPEN ORGANICALLY.
IT WAS THE SAME HOPE MITCH
McCONNELL EXPRESSED.
TRUMP DISCREDITED HIMSELF.
A LOT OF THE PUBLIC DOESN'T SEE
THAT.
>> I WANT TO PLAY ANOTHER CLIP
FROM THAT DAY.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT SENSE OF
REVENGE ABATED?
>> NO, IT HAS NOT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW TRUMP HAS
CHOSEN TO ENGAGE IN THE 2022
MIDTERM ELECTIONS, SO MUCH IS
DRIVEN BY TAKING VENGEANCE ON
PEOPLE.
TAKING VENGEANCE ON SOMEONE LIKE
BRIAN KEMP.
NO CRITIC OF DONALD TRUMP.
BUT HE WOULDN'T TRY TO OVERTURN
THE RESULTS.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT IN THAT CLIP
WE HEARD, YOU HEAR GRAHAM SAYING
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE REPORT, KEVIN McCARTHY
SAID, DRAWING A STRAIGHT LINE
BETWEEN IRRESPONSIBLE RHETORIC
AND ACTUAL ACTS OF VIOLENCE.
THAT IS ONE OF THE DYNAMICS THAT
IN THOSE DAZE REPUBLICAN PARTY
LEADERS WERE WILLING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND WRESTLE WITH AND
MAYBE EVEN TRY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT.
>> I WANT TO PLAY WHAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT SAID ABOUT
CHENEY THAT SENATOR GRAHAM WAS
REFERENCING.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT THAT CREATED
A SENSE OF REVENGE.
>> I THINK THAT'S A CRUCIAL
MOMENT.
NOT ONLY ON JANUARY 6, NOT ONLY
IN THIS BOOK, BUT IN RECENT
AMERICAN HISTORY.
SINGLING OUT THE DAUGHTER OF A
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT BY NAME AT
A RALLY THAT WOULD LEAD TO THE
STORMING AND ATTEMPTED
INSURRECTION AT THE U.S. CAPITOL
THAT DAY.
IT SHAPED LIZ CHENEY SINCE THEN.
YOU HEARD SENATOR GRAHAM.
HE WAS NOT ALONE.
A LOT OF LAWMAKERS HEARD TRUMP
MENTION CHENEY BY NAME AND WERE
APPALLED THAT HE WOULD DO THAT
BEFORE A CROWD THAT TURNED OUT
TO BE A MOB.
IT PUT PEOPLE'S LIVES IN
JEOPARDY.
SHE HAS TO HAVE SECURITY SERVICE
BECAUSE OF THE THREATS AGAINST
HER AS WE DETAIL IN THE BOOK.
A LOT OF THE CLIMATE THAT THE
GOP HAS FOSTERED TODAY, YOU CAN
REALLY TRACE BACK TO THAT SPEECH
TRUMP GAVE THE MORNING OF
JANUARY 6.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE OLD GUARD
THOUGHT THAT THAT WOULD BE THE
TRIGGER.
FINALLY, IT WOULD BE OKAY TO
WALK AWAY FROM TRUMP.
THE PARTY WOULD HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THOSE LEADERS
WERE WRONG.
THEY DIDN'T GET THEIR VOTES.
THEY WERE NOT TIRED OF TRUMP.
THEY ARE STILL HAPPILY IN HIS
EMBRACE ANDERSON, IT WAS MOMENT
--
MOMENTS AFTER THAT LIZ CHENEY
SAYS